Mary Anning the woman who helped
discover dinosaurs Mary Anning was born
into a poor family in Lyme Regis on the
south coast of England in 1799 as a
child she loved strolling across the
beach and cliffs with her father
he was a cabinetmaker who earned extra
money by searching for fossils
he taught Mary everything he knew about
them they sold the fossils to tourists
on a stall outside their house but one
night tragedy struck while walking over
the cliffs her father slipped and fell
his injuries were serious weakened from
the fall he died soon after from
tuberculosis his death left the family
devastated and in great debt their lives
became a struggle for survival to help
make ends meet Mary continued her
father's fossil business without him
one day Mary's brother spotted an
unusual skull in the cliffs 12 year old
Mary's searched relentlessly for the
rest of the fossilized bones and dug
them out she had found the skeleton of a
prehistoric reptile the ichthyosaur the
bizarre-looking creature was half fish
half lizard her discovery was evidence
of a highly controversial theory at the
time extinction many Christians were
shocked and confused as to why God would
let a species die out
Mary was noticed by educated geologists
who started to come to her for advice
later aged 22 Mary discovered the first
please Yasur skeleton experts thought
her new find was a fake but eventually
she was proven right women weren't
accepted in the geological society in
Mary's time so she wasn't properly
credited for her groundbreaking
discoveries some men even gave lectures
introducing her new finds without any
mention of the woman who had discovered
them but Mary remained determined she
saved up for a shop to sell her fossils
and continued searching for ancient
Jurassic creatures she studied the rocks
so carefully that she could even spot
coprolites lumps of fossilized poo
despite all of this she was still not
well-respected in the local community
and remained very poor things got worse
her beloved dog Trey was killed in a
landslide and she became sick with
breast cancer the medicine she was given
made her wobbly the locals sneered at
her calling her a drunk
sadly Mary Anning died aged just 47 in
1846 only on her deathbed did she begin
to get the respect she deserved the
Geological Society of London made her an
honorary member and began to write about
her life's achievements now her
outstanding contribution to paleontology
is fully recognized and she is a
celebrated woman of science it's often
said that the famous tongue twister she
sells seashells on the seashore was
based on the life of Mary Anning but
it's hard to say for sure the truth is
buried in the sands of time
you